regardez la plaque du camion dit non
bien sûr que non moi il dit le la marque
du camion non plus bah il dit bien sûr
non plus qu'est-ce que vous me pétez les
couilles alors là le commissaire comment
c'est un petit peu avoir les abeilles il
lui dit mais dites-moi quand même
monsieur vous pouvez peut-être quand
même me dire si c'était un éléphant
d'Afrique
ou un éléphant d'Asie
de ma gueule
j'habite à Sarcelles moi qu'est-ce que
j'y connais
[Applaudissements]
et là le commissaire Lucie il est en
colère Holly vous savez très bien ce que
je veux dire c'est très bien que
l'éléphant d'Afrique il y a des grandes
oreilles
l'éléphant d'Asie il a des petits
oreilles on va dire je peux pas vous
dire il avait une cagoule